bonjour à vous jean philippe tanguy
députés bonjour je suis merci d'avoir
accepté tous les deux d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre en guise eu cet
exercice du débat entre vous peut-être
que sur les retraites vous avez entendu
le ministre justifier la réforme qui va
manifestement être présenté au parlement
et vous voulez peut-être poursuivre sur
ce sujet cet angle oui monsieur
minispace que les élections législatives
ont envoyé différents messages au
gouvernement mais notamment le fait que
vous étiez minoritaires et sans doute
les français ont voulu vous dire qu'il
ne voulait plus que vous gouvernez de
façon verticale en imposant des réformes
non concertée et j'avoue qu'il était
stupéfait de la manière dont semble-t-il
monsieur macro et votre gouvernement
veut procéder à cette réforme c'est que
nous apprenons nous députés
parlementaires et les français au même
moment que cette réforme qui est si
importante pour les français qui est si
importante pour leur pouvoir d'achat
pour leur niveau de vie pour même là la
valeur travail pour ce que représente le
travail pour des milliers des millions
de français seraient adoptés au détour
d'un appel ffs à redon dont on ne
connaît toujours pas la teneur je suis
stupéfait sachant que madame borgne a
reçu deux fois madame le pen à des
réunions monsieur macron a reçu une âme
le pen aussi jamais ce sujet n'a été
évoquée de cette façon je crois encore
que le prélat république a été clair il
a dit très clairement dans sa campagne
électorale qu'il souhaitait réformer le
système de retraite pour assurer son
financement et qu'il était favorable au
report à 65 ans de l'âge
légal de départ en retraite je crois que
vous êtes d'ailleurs votre candidate
n'était pas favorable à ces absolument
pas voilà donc ya des divergences mais
il a été très clair pendant sa campagne
et il est très clair sur le fait qu'il
veut le faire appliquer cette réforme le
plus vite possible pour assurer pour
toutes les raisons que j'ai évoquées
tout à l'heure le financement il avait
la gym d'entre elles concerne les
mesures y est évidemment et donc l'a pas
dit qu'ils allaient le faire au détour
d'un projet loi de sécurité sur le
financement sécurité sociale qui n'a
rien à voir alors là la méthode de
pour passer cette réforme n'a pas encore
été tranchée est ce que ça sera
effectivement un amendement dans le
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale un projet loi manifestement
manifestez vous n'êtes pas favorable à
ce que ça soit comme ça et permet en
fait même au sein d'autres majorités
côté on verra pour l'instant la décision
n'est pas prise j'entends votre point de
vue et je vous dis que ce n'est pas
honteux et ce n'est pas quelque chose de
scandaleux que de discuter dans un
projet de loi de finances de sécurité
sociale des réformes comme par exemple
le rallongement de l'âge légal de départ
en retraite parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est un rentrer dans le débat
public depuis des années tout le monde
parle de ces questions là depuis des
années ça a été au coeur de la campagne
présidentielle donc tout le monde sait
les positions des uns et des autres
olivier dussopt encore aujourd'hui
discuter avec les organisations
syndicales de ces questions là et donc
il ya un moment donné on va trancher on
va trancher parce que le primat
république est élu pour décider pour
réformer dossier reste à discuter non
plus crier il a été élu mais entendaient
aussi que la représentation nationale
qui a été désigné par les français a
envoyé aussi un contre mais la table et
vous ne l'entendez pas visiblement mm
vous aujourd'hui vous ne savez pas ce
soir pour nous dire à moi députés
représentant du premier groupe
d'opposition si la semaine prochaine le
texte sauf erreur qui va être présenté
au conseil des ministres contient oui ou
non une des réformes les plus
importantes du cac a eu une des raisons
qui est au coeur d'une des réformes qui
est au coeur des inquiétudes de nombreux
français y compris ceux de ma
circonscription des travaux difficiles
qui ont des métiers difficiles et qui
veulent savoir si oui ou non ils vont
travailler jusqu'à 62 64 ou 65 ans et
comprenait comment pouvez-vous justifier
que la représentation nationale elle
même ne lâche pas de quoi va-t-il a
effectué vers la représentation
nationale saura de quoi elle a discuté
le moment venu et bien sûr que laura le
temps discuter le moment venu de tous
les sujets qui seront à l'ordre du jour
j'en suis le garant d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ya une session
extraordinaire qui permet justement de
travailler les textes qui vont arriver
au début de la session d'octobre le
plfss arrivant un peu plus tard dans
l'automne est bien évidemment qui aura
tout le temps de discuter de toutes les
mesures comprises dans le plfss et dans
le plfr les retraites qu'ils ont la peau
sur les retraites comme sur les autres
sujets monsieur le député et dont tu es
vraiment regarder regardez les gains
potentiels seraient contraints pour les
salaires de projet de loi donc il n'y a
pas autant de temps qu'on voudrait mais
pour répondre à vos questions à martine
chez nos positions les très simple nous
on prend en fait comme comme base la l2
dès le début du travail début de de la
carrière pourquoi parce que on a
remarqué que d'une manière générale la
plupart des personnes qui commencent à
travailler tôt ont des métiers les plus
difficiles et donc à partir de ces taxes
et 42 annuités donc quelqu'un qui a
travaillé avant 18 ans partira souvient
bien de la proposition voilà vous me le
demandez là là non mais la perdition par
rapport à ça on sera comme ça veut dire
tout fait l'âge légal ou la durée de
cotisation mais nous aussi on est contre
les deux pour nous les deux c'est cette
réforme les femmes et non
non parce qu'il ya une façon de
travailler aux dames article me suis
désolé des institutions dans ce pays il
ya et principes mêmes de riz de la
méthode et wiba slovène s'est une fois
de plus mettre les français devant le
fait accompli met les parlementaires
devant le fait accompli c'est une c'est
déloyal parce que vous savez très bien
que le gouvernement met six maîtres de
l'ordre du jour maîtres des débats vous
avez le 49-3 donc est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui que le pays avec les
tensions qu'il ya dans le pays avec les
angoisses qu'il ya sur la crise
énergétique le pouvoir d'achat la
sécurité l'immigration vous voulez
rajouter encore un clivage aussi violent
avec les organisations syndicales avec
les partis politiques la réponse sociale
essentielle ou prend personne en
traîtrise où il vous est loisible à
extrader le prix la république a fait
une campagne là dessus il a dit non
d'ailleurs il a peut-être perdu des voix
ce moment là parce que des gens viennent
on veut pas de 65 des minoritaires cette
question non non il était élu le prix la
république et salit lui son lot de
produits tout c'est ça ils ont d'alsace
et ça sinon c'est une transformation de
des 10,2 des votes
de du printemps que leur assemblée
nationale et la france insoumise a trop
tendance à faire le pré la république a
été élu il a été clair il a trahi
personne et il a été transparent sur ce
qu'il voulait faire deuxièmement il ya
une méthode qui dont la dont les
modalités ne sont pas encore
complètement finalisé mais il y aura
bien sûr et de la concertation était
partenaires sociaux ait un débat dans
l'opinion publique et un débat au
parlement ça c'est clair net et précis
et bien évidemment comprendre en compte
dans cette réforme les carrières longues
la pénibilité
parce que c'est important de le prendre
encore deux mois mais y est c'est aussi
et prendre en compte tafer voleuse
niveau le niveau minimum des pensions de
retraite et enfin pardon peut-être que
la différence entre vous et moi c'est
que nous nous sommes très clairement à
dire la vérité aux français c'est mentir
aux grands mais c'est mentir aux
français que de leur dire
que l'on peut leur assurer la
pérennisation de leur raison d'être si
si on ne réforme pas la durée légale et
ça c'est le travail à la question mais
oui c'est ce que vous savez vous en
permanence et c'est nécessaire de dire
la vérité aux français
la réforme est morte en route donc vous
savez vous pouvez pas dire on a dit la
vérité ya cinq ans redire une autre
vérité ma mini gay eu là ça vous arrange
c'est la vérité il faut vivre ça fait
très bien et que une réforme comme celle
là ne pouvait pas se passer dans pleine
crise co-lead on va avancer bien sûr
mais
la pérennité des comptes est assurée
pour vous les français mais vous savez
une amertume ce sont des choix
politiques on n'est pas élu pour subir
les événements n'est pas élu pour subir
un système économique qu'on n'est pas
comment des investissements à le
financer mais vous savez nous monsieur
reste et on a un grand plan pour
réindustrialiser la france pour recréer
de la reflex sur le territoire à partir
du moment où nous aurons recrée de la
crise sur le territoire le financement
des retraites il est assuré le déficit
avec lequel vous essayez de terroriser
les français d'ailleurs cette année
finalement ce n'est pas un déficit ce
qui prouve bien que la vérité d'hier
n'est pas forcément la vérité de demain
compte tenu des circonstances
économiques c'est que vous subissez les
choses et en fait vous l'avez d'ailleurs
dit une part considérable de cette
réforme des retraites ne vise pas à
assurer la pérennité du système des
retraites mais à financer d'autres
réformes la dépendance malhonnête et une
fois de plus de le dire mais c'est parce
que vous avez dit aux français vous avez
dit le système des retraites est menacée
dont les formes il est pas menacé vous
voulez faire financer d'autres choses
donc si vous voulez financer bas vous
venez de le dire donc si vous voulez
financer d'autres choses avec la réforme
des retraites c'est bien alors votre
dernière réponse il en parle et on parle
après l'énergie il faut financer le
système de retraites le cor vient de
dire encore une fois que a très vite
courte échéance il y aurait des déficits
majeurs donc ça vous le refusez de le
voir et vous refusez dents définitives
et en même temps on assume le fait de
dire que en plus on a besoin de financer
effectivement un certain nombre
d'éléments de pérennisation de notre
protection sociale et d'investissement
pour assurer des services publics et de
lutte contre et les luttes la lutte
contre l'inégalité à l'origine ils n'ont
donc rien à voir avec la pérennité du
système des retraites mais qui est
complémentaire l'année si
les deux il ya les deux on l'a su on le
dit aux français oui vous qui refusez
d'abord une autorité aux personnes qui
pensent que marine ne dit pas la vérité
aux français aussi beaucoup de moi le
premier
sur ce repart c'est un sujet aussi été
très très important pour les français
c'est évidemment l'énergie on a beaucoup
parlé du parc nucléaire voilà je crois
que sur le système de aussi de
répartition de l'énergie européen
vouliez interpellé franck riester
monsieur monsieur mini parce que vous
savez que nous dénonçons depuis sa
création d'ailleurs la méthode de calcul
du prix de marché de l'électricité au
niveau européen savons aussi dénoncé
depuis le début le système de la reine
qui a considérablement affaibli df et
spolier les français qui avaient financé
le parc nucléaire est une fois plus vous
subissez les événements ça fait des mois
que nous savons ce système ne marche
plus a fait même des mois que vous même
avec la présidence française du conseil
de l'union européenne vous aviez dit
qu'il fallait réformer ce système il
n'est toujours pas réformé nous entrons
donc dans le deuxième hiver où les prix
sont complètement hors contrôle un pays
deux pays qui sont beaucoup moins
souverain sur leur production
d'électricité à savoir l'espagne et le
portugal sont sortis de ce système
effectivement tous les français peuvent
voir qu'aujourd'hui et encore vérifier
avant de venir le portugal paie son
électricité entre 150 et 200 euros le
mégawattheure nounou payé entre 400 et
600 euros donc on voit bien que la
décision des espagnols et des portugal a
été raisonnable est la nôtre nous
continuons à subir et en fait alors
rentrer en donc ma question c'est
pourquoi alors que la france est
souveraine sur 93% son électricité
nucléaire hydraulique éolien vous
choisissez de subir ce système européen
qui est très cher pour les français et
vous ne sortez pas de ces règles qui
sont complètement dysfonctionnelle on
souhaite la réforme du système
effectivement de calcul de prix fixation
du prix l'énergie c'est un combat du
présent dans le public du ministre de
l'économie et bono le maire et nous
avons la ferme ambition de réussir comme
nous l'avons fait pour d'autres combats
des combats que j'ai menés par exemple
sur la réciprocité d'ouverture des
marchés publics dans le secteur de la
politique commerciale où le combat de la
mise en place d'un mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
être en européen c'est être plus forts
face
et pas nous c'est plus fort par rapport
à la concurrence internationale mais en
même temps ça nécessite un peu plus de
temps pour convaincre certains
partenaires arrivé à l'arrivée à nos
fins six essais ce travail là que nous
faisons c'est notre électro gars y
restèrent thaddée notre électricité on
veut absolument avoir besoin aussi de la
solidarité européenne cet hiver mais si
on a un hiver notamment rigoureux donc
la solidarité va pas dans les deux sens
la session se désole que si maintenant
est-ce que l'espagne et la france est
forte de l'électricité basse ronde
échange de l'électricité avec un grand
nombre de pays européens c'est parfois
avec la mélamine qui est sorti du
système bas l'espagne on a des échanges
et d'énergie avec l'espace est possible
de sortir de ce système de formation des
prix tout en déchargeant d'électricité
vous êtes d'accord attendez nous nous
souhaitons réformer au niveau européen
et pas répondre à cette question qui
dérange les signaleurs en soi mais agit
mais non vous me dites ah bah si on sort
du système y aura plus d échanges mais
je vous dis l'espagne et la france
continuent d'échanger d'électricité
alors que l'espagne est sortie de ce
système et nous nous continuons à payer
pour un système ce que l'échangé chaque
pays a des réalités d'énergétique et de
mix énergétique différent l'espagne est
plus dépendante de ses importations et
du gaz que la france donc pourquoi
est-ce que la france qui est en
situation plus favorable qui est le fait
au dos nucléaire de l'europe continue à
subir avec malgré tout des difficultés
on encore l'équipe à sion soit votre
avantage parce que la demande est élevée
est d'accélérer la remise en place d'un
certain de la remise à niveau d'un
certain nombre d'axés bien leur demandez
vous êtes responsable vous êtes le la
tutelle d'edf oui mais pourquoi est-ce
que ça compte vous subissez ce système
alors que les espagnols et le mur final
de lutter parvenant veut le repaf mais
il ya deux solutions soit on sort d'un
système où on essaye de le réformer eh
bien nous on pense qu'il faut le
réformer en l'espagne et le portugal
c'est temporaire mais c'est le temps des
jeux
ils ont fait un choix qui n'est pas le
nôtre je vous fais débrouiller mais
annonce explique pourquoi on vous
expliquer pas bassine nous dit on l'a
pas fait parce qu'on l'a pas fait bon
non non je suis je dit on l'a pas fait
parce que l'on déformé doivent payer non
pas ma vision des plaignards à des
partenaires que l'on souhaite réformer
les espagnols et sortent nerfs mais si
c'est des partenaires bon alors on peut
pas dire à des partenaires avec lesquels
on est dans un système en commun qu'on
veut quitter qu'on quitte le système et
qu'on leur ait on l'aurait formes
arrondies on reste dans le système on
leur réforme et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire deux hivers froids hivers
quatre hivers le faux via divers on va
payer et bien écoutez je pense que les
choses sont en train d'évoluer vous avez
entendu les déclarations de la
présidente de la commission européenne
qui veut prendre ce dos qui prend ce
dossier à bras le corps et donc nous
sommes un an qu'on dit ça mais c'est
vrai que ça passe ça prend parfois un
peu de temps
oui tout à fait comme moi que je suis
j'ai été très vite et très choqué parce
que sa tête vous déplaît mes enfants
vient d'une matrice commune qui était
l'ump où on avait comme un respect des
institutions des entreprises publiques
du service de l'état j'ai été très
choquée que vous mettiez en que votre
gouvernement mettant les monsieur madame
monsieur maquereau en particulier
mettent en cause monsieur lévy d'une
manière aussi indécentes sur la place
publique comme si il était responsable
des décisions que vous avez prises tous
les experts s'accordent à dire que le
fait d'avoir annoncé la fermeture de 14
réacteurs d'une heure
à désorganiser la filière donc vous êtes
responsable de cette décision edf n'a
fait qu'appliquer la loi et vous dites
aujourd'hui que c'est la faute de
monsieur lévy donc comment vous pouvez
dire aux français alors que dans la
région de chartres balayer devant sa
porte et assumer ses responsabilités les
livres à son goût notre allée de prendre
les décisions qui permettent de
pérenniser un système et de s'inscrire
dans l'avenir c'est ce qu'a fait le
président république en étant très clair
en annonçant
la construction de 6 nouveaux pères et
d'avoir une tranche de 800 dans la loi
la fermeture des deux réacteurs est
toujours dans la loi celle des six
réacteurs n'émanerait donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il a pris une
décision et il y aura le moment venu
elle est très théorique nou lé pas très
théorique elle est très pratique et s'il
ya des mais ses détracteurs faire s'il
ya s'il ya des nécessité de modifier la
loi en la matière nous le ferons le mois
c'est dans la loi la fermeture dernier
marc lemay dragon mort a indiqué la loi
le moment venu et en ce qui concerne le
dr en ce qui concerne edf ils ont as
vous à madame martineau ce qui concerne
des filons à assurer la maintenance des
réacteurs donc plutôt que parfois de
reprocher à l'état un certain nombre de
décisions c'est bien aussi de veiller à
entretenir et vous ne m'avez l'air la
maintenance des réacteurs voilà c'était
pas tout seul ça va il faut devenir des
ouvriers qui sont floués et qui sont et
qui sont d'aider des personnes de grand
talent et qui ont une grande force qui
n'ont pas du tout apprécié de la mise en
cause
côté peut-être mais en tout cas nous
qu'on considère c'est que l'énergie
nucléaire est important dans le mix
énergétique ça suffit pas d'ailleurs les
les propositions de marine le pen de
supprimer ces renouvelables à terme sont
irresponsables
c'est un mixte entre des énergies
renouvelables parce qu'il y avait
d'autres sources d'énergie électrique
que le nucléaire il y avait notamment le
charbon ou le gaz et donc il ya besoin
de monter le nôtre puissance de
production énergétique par le
renouvelable et de continuer à pousser
le nucléaire qui est absolument clé dans
notre mix énergétique de fournisseurs de
fourniture d'électricité dans l'avenir
ils font les et en ce qui concerne le
nucléaire le prénom république a été
très clair il soutient la filière il
veut investir dans l'avenir savoir
fermer deux réacteurs annoncé 12 après
avoir constaté la mise en oeuvre d'une
décision qui était prêtre qui précédait
son arrivée à l'elysée conseillers
notion londres merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir posé les arguments sur la
table sur ces deux sujets merci beaucoup
jean philippe tanguy d'avoir élevé à
cette émission